you've probably found this video by
scrolling on your phone procrastinating
from doing something important here's
some advice from one of the world's
leading experts in procrastination on
why waiting to feel motivated is the
worst thing you can do right now
motivation should follow action not the
other way around
it's my this is huge right I don't know
where people learn this notion that they
have to feel like they have to be in the
mood but that's part of the
procrastinator song I don't want to I
don't feel like it'll feel more like it
tomorrow it's as if we're waiting for
our Muse we're waiting for that bus to
come that's going to pick us up and give
us our motivation I'd say motivation is
at the intersection of Will and skill
when my will and my skill match and I'm
challenging myself just a little bit
beyond perhaps what my skill level can
be but I'm working hard and I completely
lose myself and I get into the magical
state of flow and then I use the word
already that's when the magic happens